Here's a,
here's a counter example.
Let's say you're trying to smoke,
trying to quit smoking,
you're trying to quit smoking.
Okay.
And your friends smoke.
Okay,
so what do they do it like do they
offer you a cigarette at every possible
opportunity?
Cause that's very common.
People do that very commonly.
Why?
Well maybe they're mad that maybe they're
mad that they can put smoking or maybe
if you quit and they didn't,
that would cast a bit
them in a bad shadow.
Or maybe they're just being malevolent
or maybe it's a game or whatever.
But one of the things it isn't is in
the best interest of the person who's
trying to quit smoking or
drinking or eating or you know,
or behaving in any sort of dismal manner
that's self defeating across time.
And so one of the things that,
you know,
I had a client just a while back and he
was talking about an older sibling and
he used to make these
models very complicated,
more so he was quite young at this time.
His sibling was like a
decade and a half older.
So he was like 10 or something like that.
Make these really complex models.
He'd spend a couple of weeks building
them and then when the older sibling came
in and he just smashed them up,
it's like,
well,
let's see what kind of
stress this thing can take.
It's like,
okay,
what's going on there?
Well,
I wouldn't say it's unconditional positive
regard with the aim of encouraging
the person and bringing them to fruition.
It's quite the opposite and it's
an instrumental use of action.
It send the point is not to
elevate me or you or both of us.
The point is I'm going to be the
monster at the top of the hierarchy.
If you're all crunched up
and lying at the bottom,
that's just fine.
And that's a very common
set of motivations.
And you might ask,
well,
why isn't that okay?
Well,
that's a good question.
I think the right answer to that is,
as a long run game,
it's counterproductive.
No one benefits.
So there's local benefits to you
for the short in the short term.
So.